A king of New York City's skate scene,
an '80s teen queen destined for fame,
and an "animal" who left pro sports for
Japanese TV. They've been gone for years,
but these actors haven't been forgotten.
Rob Knox's portrayal of the obnoxious Marcus Belby
in "Harry Potter and the Half-Blood Prince" stands
as his first and only major part in a motion
picture. Belby is a Ravenclaw student and a
candidate for the Slug Club, a meeting
of Hogwarts' best and brightest pupils,
hosted by Professor Horace Slughorn. Knox played
the part of Belby with a sweet vulnerability.
Before he could begin filming his planned
role in "Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows,
Part 1," Knox died after an early morning
fight outside the Metro Bar in Southeast
London. Knox had just wrapped his scenes for "The
Half-Blood Prince." He was stabbed after stepping
in to thwart an attack on his younger brother,
Jamie. In the weeks leading up to the stabbing,
his killer, Karl Bishop, had altercations
with Knox and his friends. Bishop wound up
with a life sentence in prison. Rob Knox
died on May 24, 2008, at the age of 18.
For Marvel movie fans, Powers Boothe is a
familiar face. The actor portrayed Gideon Malick,
the villainous former leader of Hydra, in
"The Avengers" and "Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D."
But the character actor enjoyed a lengthy film and
television career long before his MCU role. After
years spent perfecting his craft on the stage,
Boothe made his film debut in 1980's "Cruising."
The '80s saw Boothe deliver strong performances
in films like "Red Dawn" and "The Emerald Forest."
Through four decades as an actor, Powers Boothe
appeared in over 60 films and television shows.
"Well my full attention is at your disposal."
Boothe's last film was 2014's "Sin City:
A Dame to Kill For," the follow-up to Robert
Rodriguez and Frank Miller's 2005 hit,
"Sin City." He died at the age of 68
on May 14, 2017 from pancreatic cancer.
Matthew Garber played the younger Banks child,
Michael, in the original "Mary Poppins," and
was only eight years old when he took the role.
The eldest of two boys, Garber began acting
with the encouragement of Shakespearean actor
Roy Dotrice. Garber's film debut came in
Disney's "The Three Lives of Thomasina"
when casting directors fell in love with
the boy's fun, exuberant personality.
After "Mary Poppins," Garber starred in a final
Disney film, 1967's "The Gnome-Mobile." In 1976,
a 21-year-old Garber caught hepatitis while
traveling through India. Although he returned
to the United Kingdom for treatment, it
was too late and the disease had affected
his pancreas. On June 13, 1977, Matthew
Garber died of complications from hepatitis.
Alexis Arquette was born into Hollywood royalty.
Her father, Lewis Arquette, was an actor and
director, and her mother, Brenda "Mardi"
Nowak, was an actor and activist who taught
acting classes and ran a theater. Her siblings,
Rosanna, Patricia, and David Arquette, would each
carve a successful path for themselves to acting
stardom. At 12 years old, Alexis took the plunge
into professional acting, starring in a music
video for the song "She's a Beauty" by The Tubes.
Born Robert Arquette, Alexis knew she was
transgender from a young age. Arquette had
sex reassignment surgery in 2006
and supported other celebrities,
like Chaz Bono, who wanted to do the same.
"I'm happy to speak about it to anyone,
even if it's somebody who I don't know.
But I certainly have boundaries, limits."
In the 1980s, she broke ground for transgender
youth. At 19, she played a trans sex worker in
the 1989 film "Last Exit to Brooklyn." Arquette
starred in over 40 films through her prolific
career — although most were small, independent
movies. In the 1990s, Arquette appeared
in supporting roles in "She's All That,"
"The Wedding Singer," and "Pulp Fiction."
After contracting HIV in 1987, Arquette went
through long periods of poor health. In 2013,
she decided to live once more as a man. But
Arquette's increasing health decline could
not be reversed. On September 11, 2016, at 47,
Alexis Arquette died after being placed in a
medically-induced coma due to HIV complications.
The official cause of death was cardiac arrest.
George Gaynes enjoyed a storied acting career.
Before emigrating to the U.S. in his 30s,
Gaynes served in World War II as a member
of the Royal Netherlands Navy. He trained
at the legendary Actors Studio in New York
City in the 1950s and began his career on
Broadway. Gaynes appeared in classic 1970s
series like "The Six Million Dollar Man" and
"Columbo," often playing minor, supporting
roles. He acted in 10 films in the 1980s,
including "Tootsie," "Dead Men Don't
Wear Plaid," and "Police Academy."
George Gaynes warmed kids' hearts in
his long-lasting television portrayal
of Henry Warnimont, the kindly foster dad
of Punky on the NBC series "Punky Brewster."
Gaynes married his wife, television
actor Allyn Ann McLerie, in 1953,
and they remained together until his death.
Gaynes made his last film appearance alongside
Ashton Kutcher and Brittany Murphy in
2003's "Just Married." On February 15,
2016, at the well-seasoned age of
98, Gaynes died of natural causes.
Theresa Saldana made her film debut in 1978's
"I Wanna Hold Your Hand" and rose to fame
with her role in the Academy Award-winning film
"Raging Bull." Saldana played Lenora LeMotta, the
sister-in-law of protagonist Jake LeMotta.
Saldana quickly garnered recognition for
her acting talent, later scoring a role in
"Defiance," which also starred '80s star
Jan-Michael Vincent, and playing Rachel
Scali on the CBS series "The Commish."
"Big house on the hill, that's not the
American dream. We're the American dream."
"Damn straight."
On March 15, 1982, Arthur Richard Jackson, a
Scottish drifter who had been stalking Saldana,
approached the actor in front of her home
and stabbed her with a hunting knife.
"I did call the police on March 8th,
and they said that they couldn't send anyone
out because there wasn't enough manpower."
The actor survived the violent attack, but
was left with severe wounds and spent four
months in the hospital. Jackson
served over a decade in prison,
but continued to threaten
Saldana from his jail cell.
After her attack, Saldana founded the advocacy
group Victims for Victims. She lobbied Congress
to help establish California's 1990
anti-stalking law and the national
1994 Driver's Privacy Protection Act. Saldana
wrote a memoir about her experiences called
"Beyond Survival" and played herself in
the television film "Victims for Victims:
The Theresa Saldana Story." Saldana continued
to act on television until 2003 and on the big
screen through 2004. On June 6, 2016, at
the age of 61, Saldana died of pneumonia.
Ron Lester is probably best known for playing
Billy Bob, the fun-loving offensive guard
on the West Canaan, Texas high school
football team in 1999's "Varsity Blues."
"Hey Mox! You skinny ass b----! Let's roll!"
A Georgia native, Lester began his acting career
in commercials and appeared in a music video for
the country band Little Texas. He left Georgia
for the sunny skies of Los Angeles to pursue
acting and stand-up comedy full-time. From
1997 to 2002, Lester appeared in five films,
including "Good Burger" and "Not Another Teen
Movie." He made his last film appearance as
Roger Hardwick in 2015's "Racing Legacy"
— a film he also wrote and directed.
Lester underwent gastric bypass surgery in
2000, dropping over 300 pounds from his heavy
frame. But in 2015, he began to experience
severe liver and kidney problems from which
he never recovered. At the beginning of
June 2016, he began hospice care. Ron
Lester died of kidney and liver failure
on June 17, 2016. He was 45 years old.
For over half a century, David Huddleston
graced our cinemas and small screens. His
acting career showed impressive range,
and his character roles endeared him to
audiences, but Huddleston wasn't a household name.
You may know David Huddleston from films like
"Blazing Saddles" and the 1971 made-for-TV movie
"Brian's Song," as well as his portrayal of
the titular character in "The Big Lebowski.".
On television, Huddleston's roles ranged from
"Gilmore Girls," where he portrayed the beloved,
eccentric mayor Harry Porter, to "Bewitched,"
where he played several characters.
Huddleston grew up in post-Great Depression
rural Virginia and fell in love with acting
in his youth. His first film appearance
came via an uncredited role in 1963's
"All the Way Home." His last movie
was 2014's "Locker 13." On August 2,
2016, David Huddleston died at 85
due to heart and kidney disease.
"Okay. Who gets the privilege?"
Another respected character actor, Jon Polito
co-starred with David Huddleston in "The Big
Lebowski," where he played P.I. Da Fino.
Chances are you've seen many of Polito's
movie turns as a mobster or cop — two of the
actor's mainstay characters. His outstanding
film resume includes four other Coen Brothers
films: "Barton Fink," "The Hudsucker Proxy,"
"The Man Who Wasn't There," and the epic "Miller's
Crossing." He also played Detective Steve Crosetti
on the NBC television show "Homicide:
Life on the Street," from 1993 to 1994.
Polito studied theater at Villanova University. By
the time he was 30, he began regularly working in
Hollywood productions. Although his roles were
often typecast, Polito uniquely crafted each
character. In a time when many actors remained
closeted, Polito was openly gay and married his
longtime partner, Darryl Armbruster, on
October 16, 2015. On September 1, 2016,
less than a year after his wedding, Polito
died due to multiple myeloma. He was 65.
Brad Lesley's name may have more
recognition with hardcore baseball
fans than with moviegoers. Known as "The Animal"
for his brawn, height, and in-game theatrics,
the six-foot-six-inch Lesley played
major league baseball from 1982 to 1985.
Lesley moved to Japan in 1986, where he
played for two seasons before retiring
from baseball and becoming a Japanese television
personality. His larger-than-life stature and
persona made him a fan favorite on the
Japanese game show "Takeshi's Castle."
In the 1990s, Lesley began appearing in
Hollywood films as well. He was best-known
for the roles that reflected aspects of his
personal life, like Niven in "Mr. Baseball"
and John "Blackout" Gatling in "Little
Big League." Lesley began to experience
declining health in the 2010s. After his kidneys
failed, he was placed on dialysis and moved
into a nursing home. On April 28, 2013, Brad
Lesley suffered a heart attack and died at 54.
Alberta Watson spent her early adulthood
carving a career in Canadian television
and movie productions, but soon
plunged into Hollywood work and
landed meaty parts in a variety
of films and television shows.
"I don't tolerate any weaknesses.
That's not how I work."
In the critically-acclaimed transgender musical
"Hedwig and the Angry Inch," Watson played the
loving mother of Hansel "Hedwig" Schmidt.
Her dark turn as the incestuous mother in
David O. Russell's directorial debut,
"Spanking the Monkey," stood as one of
her favorite roles. She also appeared
in "The Sweet Hereafter" and "Hackers."
Watson's last film role was 2009's "Helen." She
ended her TV career in 2012 with them,.recurring
role of Senator Madeline Pierce on "Nikita."
Watson was first diagnosed with lymphoma in
1998, and died of complications from
cancer on March 21, 2015 at age 60.
Throughout her elementary school years, Amanda
Peterson starred in local theater productions in
her hometown of Greeley, Colorado. It didn't
take long for Peterson to score an agent,
and after guest appearances on hit '80s shows
like "Silver Spoons" and "Father Murphy," Peterson
starred on the big screen in "Explorers,"
alongside River Phoenix and Ethan Hawke.
It was Peterson's role as the popular cheerleader
Cindy Mancini in 1986's "Can't Buy Me Love"
that endeared her to audiences. Although
she appeared destined for meteoric fame,
Peterson's blazing Hollywood
career seemed to fizzle by 1994.
"Work's not really my thing."
She retired from acting and
returned to life in Colorado.
Peterson struggled to navigate through her
post-celebrity life. She turned to drugs
and soon developed a severe addiction. After
several arrests, Peterson attempted to regain
her life. Friends told the Denver Post that in
her later days, she spoke of getting back into
acting — she dreamed of opening a studio for
young, aspiring actors. Amanda Peterson died
of an accidental morphine overdose on July 3,
2015, three days short of her 44th birthday.
Bridgette Andersen's name may not ring
a bell, but by the early '80s, she had
appeared in a plethora of commercials.
After several TV guest appearances,
Andersen landed the starring role in 1982's
"Savannah Smiles," playing Savannah Driscoll,
a young runaway who befriends two convicts.
Andersen received a Young Artist
Award nomination for her work and
appeared to be a star on the rise, but
acting roles dried up by the time she
reached her teenage years. Her last film
appearance came in 1987's "Too Much."
Bridgette Andersen died on May 18, 1997,
of an opioid overdose at 21 years old.
In the early 1990s, Christopher Lee Pettiet's
classic good looks and natural talent helped
him land multiple television appearances on
shows like "Doogie Howser, M.D." and "Star Trek:
The Next Generation." His early film roles
included "Point Break" and "Sandman."
But Pettiet is best known for his performance
as the middle brother, Zach Crandell,
in the 1989 cult classic "Don't Tell Mom the
Babysitter's Dead." The black comedy initially
tanked at the box office and was panned by
critics, but eventually gained a large cult
following. Pettiet earned teen heartthrob
status and steady work due to his role,
including parts in the ABC series "The Young
Riders" and the 1996 indie film "Boys."
On April 12, 2000, Pettiet died from an
accidental drug overdose. He was 24 years old.
Ashleigh Aston Moore is best known for
her role as Chrissy in 1995's "Now and
Then," playing the young counterpart to Rita
Wilson's adult character in flashback scenes.
"Chrissy. Let go of your inhibitions
before you dry up like a prune."
"What's that supposed to mean?"
"Now and Then" stood out as a female-driven
film full of rich character development,
painting a realistic portrait of the
tween years and becoming a favorite
shared movie experience for many young girls.
Like so many child actors, Moore began
appearing in commercials when she was
barely out of diapers. But her acting career
began to fade after her turn in "Now and
Then." She made her last screen appearance in
1997, in an episode of "Touched by An Angel."
Moore opted out of the Hollywood life,
and moved to Vancouver, British Columbia,
Canada. According to friends, she'd developed
an addiction to heroin while still in her teens,
which continued through her
adulthood. At the age of 26,
Ashleigh Aston Moore died of an accidental
heroin overdose on December 10, 2007.
Growing up in the projects of the
East Village in New York City,
Harold Hunter developed a passion
for skateboarding. He spent most
of his time skating in city parks, where he
quickly gained attention from skate apparel
companies. Hunter was featured in Thrasher
magazine in 1989 and sponsored by Zoo York.
He snagged modeling jobs for prominent
fashion companies like Tommy Hilfiger.
Hunter symbolized the New York City skate kids'
culture, and remained the reigning "king" of the
city's skate parks well into adulthood. After
starring as Harold in "Kids," Hunter appeared
in an episode of "New York Undercover"
and held minor roles in independent films.
On February 17, 2006, Harold Hunter
died at the age of 31 of myocardial
infarction — a heart attack induced by cocaine.
Best known for his roles as the woefully-named
"Half Sack" on the FX drama "Sons of Anarchy"
and "Chili" on Fox's "The O.C.,"
Johnny Lewis left the Hollywood
community reeling in shock on September 26,
2012. He killed 81-year-old Cathy Davis,
a longtime friend to artists and the
landlady of the Writer's Villa. Lewis,
who had previously rented a suite from Davis
in 2009, had just moved back into the home.
After killing Davis, Lewis fell to
his death from the villa's roof.
In the months leading up to his
death, Lewis had exhibited strange,
violent behavior and had spent time
in Twin Towers Correctional Facility
for committing several acts of unprovoked
violence. He experienced constant legal and
mental health issues between 2009
and his death at age 28 in 2012.
Justin Pierce dropped out of high school
and became part of the skateboarding scene
in New York City in the early '90s. Trouble
with drugs and criminal activity peppered
Pierce's teen years, but a role in the
1995 film "Kids" would provide an escape.
Photographer-turned-director Larry Clark
discovered the 19-year-old skateboarding
in Washington Square Park with his friends.
The fledgling director offered Pierce his
first starring film role as obnoxious Casper,
the best friend of "Kids" protagonist Telly.
"They way I see it? My outlook on the situation?"
"Mr. Wizard."
"It's like getting fame,
you know what I'm saying?"
The controversial film resonated with
teenage audiences and critics alike,
and Pierce won an Independent Spirit
Award for his role. He continued to
connect with viewers through his authentic
portrayal of troubled teens, going on to
star in "A Brother's Kiss," "Next Friday,"
and other independent films. Unfortunately,
Pierce's life issues followed him
to Hollywood. While in Las Vegas to
promote "Next Friday," the then 25-year-old
actor took his own life on July 10, 2000.
Best known for playing Geoffrey Barone on
"Everybody Loves Raymond," Sawyer Sweeten
was cast with his twin brother, Sullivan, at
just 23 months old. Though the twins were cast
together on the Ray Romano vehicle, Sawyer went on
to land a film role without his brother. In 2002,
the actor played a young Frank McKlusky in
"Frank McKlusky, C.I." The film didn't fare well
at the box office and was panned by critics, but
Sawyer proved he could act on the silver screen.
Sawyer grew up in the limelight, and by all
accounts was a funny and kind kid. Sadly,
things came to an abrupt end when he took his
own life on April 23, 2015, at just 19 years old.